bir gz çik 9 sınıf öcer jf kotar
okulundan YouTube'un en büyük jf
kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Paraf z
takım okula destek kampımızı bugün
geldik artık 9 gününe artık 3ün üniteye
geçtik şimdi dur bundan önceki
ünitelerde şimdi böyle günlük hani
diyoruz ya coğrafya günlük hayatla
alakalı bundan önceki ünitelerde de sana
günlük hayatla alakalı olan kısımlarını
gösterdik haritaların falan ama günlük
hayatta öyle aşırı derecede
kullandığımız şeyler değildi onlar o
konuları sevmediysen coğrafyaya karşı ön
yargılı olma çünkü Bundan sonraki
konular çok e en celi olacak bunlar tam
hayatın içinde iklime geldik Mesela şu
an iklimin elemanlarını değişenlerin
bütün sistemlerini hepsini öğreneceğiz
iklime öğreneceksin hava olaylarını
öğreneceksin günlük hayatın tam içinden
olan basıncı sıcaklığı neme öğreneceksin
her gün karşılaşıyorsun bunlarla bundan
sonra nüfus konuları gelecek mesela
günlük hayatın tam içinden olacak ve bu
konular kolay konular yorumlamanın genel
kültürünü arttıracak konular sakına ön
yargılı olma çok güzel geçecek hiç merak
etme hayatın tam içinden olan konulara
geldik artık ben şöyle kalemimi aldım
hazırım Sen de beğen tuşuna basıp abone
olarak Hazırlandı isan O zaman ne
diyoruz Yunus aayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma gelin şu konuya Paraf
atalım geldik hava olaylarına pdf' inizi
siteye yükledim zedu van.com sitesinden
indirebilirsiniz diğer hocalarımızın
pdf'leri de yine orada var Onlar da
anlatımlarını yapıyorlar Z takımı olarak
gençler bütün senelerde yanınızda
olacağız Merak etmeyin Şimdi geldik
artık ünite 3'te yiz doğal sistemler ve
süreçlerden hava olaylarına bakacağız bu
konu basit bir konu bundan sonraki
konularda hafif bir zor zorlanabilirsin
dikkatli bir şekilde dinle zor olduğu
için değil ama konular biraz daha
zorlayıcı olabilir o yüzden böyle günü
gününe çalış eğer son sınava yani
sınavdan önceki güne bırakırsan biraz
zorlanabilirsin Benden demesi O yüzden
dikkatli bir şekilde düzenli devam et
şimdi bakın bir başlık atmış bize demiş
ki hava olayları ne demek bu hava
olayları ilk önce Bunu anlaman lazım Bak
havadaki yaşanan olaylar Aslında bunlar
yani havada ne yaşıyorsun sen günlük
hayatında Rüzgar yaşıyorsun değil mi Bak
Rüzgar yaşıyorsun dışarıda bir sıcaklık
var bir basınç var nem yağış sis
bulutlanma var Hava olayları dediğimizde
Bunlar aklımıza geliyor işte bu sıcaklık
basınç Rüzgarı ayrı ayrı iklim kısmına
bu videodan sonra iklim kısmına
geçtiğimizde zaten öğreneceğiz yani
sıcaklığı ele alacağız ve bütün
ayrıntılarıyla nasıl ölçülür ne yapılır
Hepsini orada öğreneceğiz merak etme
basıncı orada öğreneceğiz Ama şunu
bilmen lazım demek ki hava olayı
dediğinde bize ha hava olayı dışarıda
yaşanan olay Rüzgar basınç nem Bunlar
aklına gelecek şimdi bu hava hav
olaylarını iki türlü işliyoruz biz yani
işliyoruz derken inceliyoruz nasıl
inceliyoruz bazı hava olaylarını kısa
süreli inceliyoruz Mesela bugün hava
sıcak Bugün hava yağışlı yarın kar
yağışı bekleniyor bak ne yaptım hepsi
bir hava olayı ama bu hava olaylarını
kısa süreli bir şekilde inceledim değil
mi İşte gençler karşımıza burada
meteoroloji çıkıyor şurada meteoroloji
Bak ne diyor kısa süreli hava olaylarını
şuranın altını çizmeni istiyorum senden
buranın püf noktası Bu kısa süreli hava
ol olaylarını gözlenebilen ölçebilen
kaydedilen bütün ayrıntılarıyla
incelenen hava olaylarıyla ilgili kısa
süreli Bak ne diyor kısa süreli
tahminlerde bulunan bilim dalıdır
buradaki püf noktamız bu kısa süreli
tahmin olacak kısa süreli hava
olaylarını zaten meteoroloji dediğimizde
aklımıza bu gelmiyor mu hani
meteorolojiden alınan bilgilere göre
Yarın hava yağışlı olacak İki gün sonra
kar yağışı bekleniyor bak ne yapıyor
kısa süreli hava olaylarını gördük bunu
kısa süreli meteoroloji işliyor Ama bunu
bir de uzun süreli işleyen var o da
Klimatoloji bakın klimatolojiye ne
demiştik Biz Klimatoloji değil de iklim
atol iklim diyorduk değil mi iklim de
hava olaylarını inceliyor gençler ama
bunları böyle kısa süreli değil yarın
kar yağacak gibi değil uzun süreli bir
şekilde işliyor yani diyor ki geliyor
mesela Akdeniz kısmına burayı 40 yıl
boyunca ölçüyor sıcaklığını basıncını
bütün değerlerini ölçüyor inceliyor ve
bu uzun süreli hava olaylarından bize
bir ortalamasını veriyor ortaya iklim
çıkıyor işte Klimatoloji uzun süreli
hava olaylarının ortalamasını işlerken
meteoroloji kısa süreli hava olaylarını
işliyor hava olayları nelerdi hava
olayları konumuz buydu sıcaklık basınç
Rüzgar nem gibi dışarıda günlük hayatta
gördüğümüz şeylerdi değil mi Evet
buradaki mantık bu burada gençler
meteorolojide meteorologlar var Bunlar
bunları inceleyip buradaki hava
olaylarını inceleyip bize hava
tahminleri yapan kişiler görüyoruz
televizyonda bir kişi çıkıyor
meteorolojiden alınan bilgilere göre
hava hava şöyle olacak diyor
meteorolojiyi aklında buradan
tutabilirsin klimatolojiye de zaten
biliyorduk Biz şuraya bakın burada
Klimatoloji Klimatoloji ile
ilgilenenlere de klimatolog deniyormuş
evet şu kısımda küçük bir not var Bu
nota bakalım şunun altını çizmeni
istiyorum senden bak bir yerdeki
sıcaklık nem basınç rüzgar gibi hava
olaylarının şurası bizim için önemli
uzun yıllar boyunca gösterdiği değişim
ikli ir yani meteoroloji kısa
Klimatoloji uzun olacak sana şöyle bir
bilgi verdiğinde ya da senden bir bilgi
istediğinde dediğinde ki sana mesela
Akdeniz'de yazlar sıcak ve kuraktır
dediğinde bak yazlar sıcak ve kurak uzun
süreli bir şey var Klimatoloji Yarın
hava kar yağışlı olacak dediğinde kısa
süreli bir şey var meteoroloji
diyeceksin böyle örneklerle sorabilir
sana iklim koşulları bizim için çok çok
değerlidir gençler Aslında iklim
koşulları bizim birçok şeyimizi
etkiliyor yani her şeyimizi desem yanlış
olmaz bizim yer şekillerinin oluşumunu
bile etkiliyor yani burada yer
şekillerinin oluşumunda dış kuvvetler
etkili niye çizmedim burayı Ya şey
bozulmuş Şurayı çizmiyor bakın bozulmuş
mu ne olmuş Ha şöyle dış Kuvvetleri
kayaçları etkiliyor kayaçların daha
hızlı aşınıp aşın mamasını etkiliyor
toprakların oluşumunu etkiliyor mesela
sıcak yağışlı yerlerde daha iyi Toprak
oluşuyor ama çöl gibi yerlerde Toprak
tam
oluşamaz bitki oluyor iklim koşulları
kötüyse çöl gibi yerlerde bitki örtüsü
zayıf oluyor akarsuların fazla akıp
akmaması suların olup ol olmamasını Eğer
sular varsa o sularda tarım yapılmasını
Eğer tarım yapabiliyorsan senin
ekonominin gelişmesini ekonomin
geliştiğinde senin ekonomik gelirini
ekonomik gelirin değiştiğinde Senin
yaşam standardını hayata bakışını bakın
bir iklim her şeyinizi etkileyebiliyor O
yüzden çok çok değerlidir gençler iklim
koşulları yaşadığınız iklim koşulları
hiç tahmin edemeyeceğiniz kadar sizin
psikolojinize kadar belki de
kişiliğinize kadar birçok şeyi
etkileyebiliyor dedik geldik hava
tahminlerine hava durumu bir yerdeki
atmosfer olaylarının şuranın altını
çiziyorsun kısa süreli tahmini Yani bir
yerin basıncı Rüzgarı nemi Sisi
sıcaklığını bize kısa süreli olarak
bildirdiklerini de hava tahmini yapılmış
oluyor Bunu da biz nereden öğreniyoruz
Meteoroloji Genel Müdürlüğünden
öğreniyoruz bu gençler bir devlet kurumu
ve devletin bakın Silahlı kuvvetlerin
tarımın ormancılığın turizmin birçok
kısmın ihtiyaç duyduğu bilgileri bize
Meteoroloji Genel Müdürlüğü veriyor
zaten Meteoroloji Genel Müdürlüğüne
girerek hava tahminlerine oradan
bakabilirsiniz birçok sitede Aslında
oradan alıyor hava tahminlerini şimdi
bakın şurada Şuradaki bilgiyi Az önce
öğretmişti size Erzurum'da kar
yağışlarına bağlı olarak karayolu
ulaşımının birkaç günlüğüne kapanması
hava durumuyla ilgilidir gördünüz mü
hava durumuyla meteoroloji ile ilgilidir
Çünkü niye kısa süreli bir şey söyledi
bize değil mi bakın hava durumu
değişkendir bu bilgileri şimdi böyle alt
alta madde olarak yazmadık Ama sen benim
yaptığım gibi maddele ştir bunu hava
durumu Yani kısa süreli hava durumu
meteoroloji değişkendir bugün kar yağışı
vardır yarın güneş Açabilir bak değişken
ikincisi dar alanlarda etkili olurlar ne
demek Mesela yarın kar yağacak mesela
Silivri bölgesinde yağacak ama karşı
tarafta yağmayacak belki Kadıköy
tarafında yağmayacak Daha dar alanları
ifade eder Az sonra bunların
karşılaştırmasını iklimle yapacağım size
ve kısa sürelidir bir gün yağar kar
Yarın yağmayı kısa süreli dar alanlarda
görülüyor ve Değişken hava durumunun
özellikleri iklim Bunun tam tersi oluyor
bakın şurada hava durumu kısa süreli
dedik Değil mi iklim ama uzun süreli
oluyor iklim dediğin zaman Antalya'da
yazlar sıcak ve kuraktır bak çok uzun
süreli gördünüz mü değişkenlik çok
fazladır hava durumunda yarın kar
yağacak sonra güneş olacak ama iklimde
değişkenlik azdır Antalya'da yazlar
sıcak ve kuraktır bunun değişmesi için
çok uzun yıllar gerekir hep yazlar sıcak
ve kurak Çünkü orada değişkenlik azdır
iklimde Klimatoloji Bak bunu Güneşli
yağmurlu bak kısa süre yağmurlu Güneşli
yarın yağmurlu güneşli olacak bulutlu
gibi terimlerle ifade ediyoruz bak bunu
sıcak kurak yağışlı iklim ifade ederken
Karadeniz yağışlıdır diyoruz hava
durumunu meteoroloji inceliyordu iklimi
de Klimatoloji inceliyor bunların
ikisinin karşılaştırılması sana büyük
bir ihtimalle sorulacak sınavında yazılı
sınavında yazılı sınavındaki 10 puanlık
ilk sorun bu olacak senin şurada bir de
halk meteorolojisi ile alakalı bir bilgi
vereyim gençler şimdi halk internet
sitesine girmeyi o kadar bilmez Tabii
artık yaşlı dedelerimiz de biliyorlar
girip oradan bakıyorlar Ama ben
hatırlıyorum mesela Dedem ne yapıyordu
biliyor musunuz şöyle bir dağa bakıyordu
dağa bakıyordu bir deniz tarafı vardı
bizde Trabzonluyum Ben denizden gelen
bir hava kütlesi biz böyle deniz
tarafına dağdan baktığımız zaman Deniz
tarafından bir hava kütlesi geliyordu
Bir de böyle dağ vardı tamam mı
arkamızda arkamızdaki dağ da arka
tarafında Erzurum tarafı vardı yani
Erzurum tarafına giden yerdi şimdi ya
denizden geliyordu bulutlar ya da
Erzurum'dan Ben hatırlıyorum küçükken
Dedem söylerdi şöyle bakardı Erzurum
tarafından Bulut geliyorsa Tamam bu
bulut yağmur getirmez diyordu ama Deniz
tarafından Bulut geliyorsa Çünkü nemli
geliyor ya A bak yağmur yağabilir
diyordu İşte biz buna hulk'ın yaptığı
buna Hulk meteorolojisi diyoruz hulk'ın
kendine göre bir Hulk
takvimlere yapardı Yani ben anneannemin
hatırlıyorum İşte şu dönem geldiğinde
Fasulyeleri ekeceğim demesi bizim
takvimi kullanmazdı yani ayrı bir takvim
dediğimiz ya mesela kalandar geldiğinde
soğuklar başlar derdi mesela halkın
Kendine göre de bir takvimi oluşurdu
Buna da halk takvimi diyoruz sizin de
varsa eğer böyle örneklerin halk takvimi
ile alakalı benim aklıma gelmedi işte n
nelerini söylüyordur şu tarihte şu şu
geldiğinde soğuklar gelecek falan diye
aşağıya yorum kısmına bırakın geldik
buraya bununla alakalı bir etkinlik
yapalım verilen hava olaylarıyla ilgili
merkezler ne olduğunu yazınız yıl
boyunca sıcak hava kütlelerinin
etkisinde kalan Merkez şimdi yıl boyunca
sıcak olan yer neresidir gençler şurası
ekvator çizgisi bakın Burası Siz Ekvator
çizgisini çizmeyi bilmeniz lazım şimdi
burada size çizilmiş vermiş ama siz
bilmeyebilir yani böyle çizik
vermeyebilir şurada Afrika var ya bu
Afrika'nın altında bir girinti var
görüyor musunuz bu girin dinin altından
geçecek şekilde çizmeniz lazım Çünkü bu
çizgiyi size vermeyebilir sorularda o
yüzden sen bunu çizebilme gerekiyor
nereden şu Afrika'nın altındaki çizgiden
karşına bir tane düz beyaz dünya hartası
çıktığında üstünde bir çizgi
bulunmadığında hemen Ekvator çizgisini
Çizeceksin Şimdi niye Önemli çünkü
Ekvator her mevsim sıcaktır e kutuplar
her mevsim soğuk arada kalan yerler orta
kuşaktır 30 60 enlemler arasında kalan
yerler orta kuşaktır bunu belirlemiş
olacaksın bize ne diyor bakın yıl
boyunca sıcak hava kütlelerinin
etkisinde kalan Merkez yıl boyunca sıcak
neresi Ekvator çizgisinin olduu yer
Hemen buraya K harfini yazdık hava
durumu ile iklim koşullarının yıl
boyunca benzerlik gösterdiği Merkez bu
cümle ne demek sana böyle sorular
gelecek hava durumuyla iklimin yıl
boyunca benzer olması Mesela geldim
şuraya geldim şöyle Kayım Kaan'ın hava
durumunu söyle desem sana ne dersin
Hocam hep sıcak hep yağmurlu dersin
değil mi peki Kaan'ın bana iklimini
söyle desem sürekli yağışlı her mevsim
yağışlı Her Mevsim sıcak dersin değil mi
Bak hava durumunda da aynı kelimeler
kullandın aynı şeyleri Yani aynı tabirle
aynı sıcaklık dedin Ee iklimde de aynı
şeyi kullandın Yani eğer bir yerde
Aslında orada hava durumu ve iklim
değişmiyorsa bu yer ya Ekvator
kısmındadır Çünkü orası günde de sıcak
ve yağmurlu yıl boyunca da sıcak ve
yağmurlu ya da Kutup kısımlarında Kutup
kısımlarında da yarın havası soğuk
diyoruz değil mi yıl boyunca Soğuk değil
mi yarın kar yağacak yıl boyunca kar
yağışlı olabilir Yani aslında hava
durumuyla iklimin bir farkının olmad
adığı yerler kutuplar ve Ekvator
çizgisinin olduğu yerlerdir Nedir o
zaman bu k l p Tamam ama Orta kuşakta Bu
böyle olmuyor yarın hava Karlı
olabiliyor ama bu yıl boyunca devam
etmiyor yıl boyunca değil kış mevsiminde
Karlı oluyor yaz mevsimi sıcak oluyor
yani hava durumuyla iklim değişkenlik
gösteriyor orta kuşak Bu soruların
mantığı Bu yıl içerisinde hava durumu
ile iklimin benzerlik göstermediği
merkezler O zaman şu orta kuşaktaki
seçeceğiz m n s r Tamam yıl boyunca
soğuk hava kütlelerinin etkisinde kalan
soğuk nerede bakın kuzeyde l p m
merkezinde kış yaşanırken aynı anda yaz
yaşanan Merkez gençler şunu unutmayın
Kuzey yarımkürede kış yaşanıyorsa Güney
yarımküre Bunun tam tersidir biz kış
yaşıyorsak Güney yarımküre Yaz Yaşar Biz
yaz yaşıyorsak Güney yarımküre kış Yaşar
bunu Eksen eğikliğinden Göstereceğim
size mevsimler kısmında Eee hangisi r o
zaman tam tersini Yaşar Tamam mıyız
şimdi geldik aşırı hava olaylarına Şimdi
biz Neyi öğrendik hava olay ını öğrendik
değil mi Hem de bir özet geçmiş olalım
hava olayları Rüzgar neem basınç bunları
öğrendik Bunlar demek hava olayı sonra
dedik ki bu hava olaylarını iki türlü
inceliyoruz dedik bir tanesi
meteoroloji değil mi Bir de doğru yazsam
bir diğeri
Klimatoloji bak kafanda otursun diye bir
tekrar ediyorum hava olayları ne dedik
Rüzgar basınç sıcaklık gibi havalar hava
olayları bunu kısa süreli meteoroloji
işliyor uzun süreli kısımlarını da
Klimatoloji işliyor dedik şimdi hava
olayını öğrendik ya Bir de bu hava
olaylarında aşırı kısımda olanlar
kısmına geldik Hava olaylarının aşırı
olanları var bir de ne demek hocam aşırı
olanları Bakın şu tabire bak bir yerde
normal meteorolojik koşulların ilerisine
geçen Bak normalin ilerisine geçen bunun
altını çiz beklenmedik Normalde orada
sıcaklıklar 10 derece 30 dereceye
çıkıyor ya da işte çok fazla Rüzgar
şiddetli rüzgarlar yok orada ama bir
anda 100 kilometreyi bulan şiddetli
rüzgarlar oluşuyor normal standardın
üstüne çıkıyorsa aşırı hava olayları
diyoruz biz bunlara Peki bu Aşırı hava
olayları neler bak hava olayı olacak
aşırı hava olayı olacak bakın sıcak hava
dalgası sıcak hava dalgası sıcaklık bir
hava olayı mı Evet aşırı sıcak hava
dalgası aşırı bir hava olayıdır mesela
çok büyük bir deprem yaşandı bu aşırı
bir hava olayı mıdır Hayır deprem bir
hava olayı değil ki bu Aşırı Hava
olaylarının tanımını unutma lütfen
diğeri bak soğuk hava bir sıcak hava
dalgası soğuk hava dalgası Bu da bir
hava olayı Fırtınalar bir hava olayı
şiddetli Yıldırım düşmeleri havada
gerçekleşir dolular aşırı yaşlar havada
gerçekleşir kuraklıklar havadan
kaynaklanan bir şey sıcaklığın yüksek
olması suyun düşmemesi kuraklık da bir
hava olayı kuraklığı unutma tamam Şu
soruyu çözelim otursun kafanızda
yukarıda verilen olayların hangileri bak
aşırı hava olayları olarak
değerlendirilebilir Yanardağ patlamaları
ile oluşan del dalgaların dalgaların çok
sayıda insanın ölümüne yol açması
yanardağ patlaması Dev Dalga bunların
ikisi de bir aşırı hava olayı değil hava
olayı değil ki Rüzgar değil sıcaklık
soğukluk değil o zaman bu hava olayı
değil tamam aşırı yağışlar bir hava
olayı mı Evet sonucu çok sayıda evin su
altında kalması bir hava olayı aşırı bir
hava olayı aşırı kuraklık kuraklık bir
havadan mı gerçekleşiyor Evet o zaman
aşırı hava olayı şiddetli deprem deprem
hava olayı mı Hayır o zaman bunu eledik
2 ve 3 cevap C buradan senin karşına
gelecek olan soruların mantığı bu işte
Demek ki aşırı Hava olaylarının ne
olduklarını bileceksin soğuk sıcaklık
kuraklık fırtına yağış şiddetli yağışlar
değil mi aşırı olacak Tabii bunlar Peki
bunlar neler Hocam mesela sıcak hava
dalgaları şunun altını çizmeni istiyorum
burada bak sıcaklığın ortalama değerinin
üzerinde art arda Önemli olan kısmı
Burası yani tamam aşırı sıcaklıklar
olacak ama biz buna ne zaman sıcak hava
dalgası diyeceğiz art arda 5 gün ve daha
üstünde olduğunda O zaman burada bir
sıcak hava dalgası vardır diyeceğiz
mesela bakın 2003 yılında Avrupa'da
etkili olan sıcak hava dalgası sonucu
çok sayıda insan yaşamını yitirmiş bakın
çeşitli Sağlık sorunlarına neden
olabilir değil mi Bazen Hani duyuru ve
uyarılar yapılıyor artık mesaj olarak da
geliyor bize işte aşırı yağış olacak
diye mesaj atıyorlar afattan falan mesaj
geliyor ya da işte yarın hava çok sıcak
olacak şu yaşın üstündeki insanların şu
saatler arasında dışarı çıkmaması
gerekiyor Neden Çünkü çeşitli Sağlık
sorunlarına neden olabiliyor bu sıcak
hava dalgaları bu sıcak hava dalgaları
gençler su kaynaklarına kuraklığa da
neden olabiliyor su kaynaklarının
buharlaşıp kuraklık derecesinin
artmasına neden olabiliyor bakın
bitkilerin kurumasına neden oluyor bu
sıcak hava dalgası Bu da yağışları
artırabiliyor mesela yaz aylarında
Akdeniz'de sürekli yangınlarla
karşılaşıyoruz çünkü yazın o kadar fazla
sıcaklıklar artıyor ki orada
sıcaklıkların arttığı günlerde Hatta
bitkilerin dallarının bile birbirine
sürterek yangına neden olduğu durumlar
yaşanabiliyor İşte o sıcak hava
dalgaları yangınların da artışına neden
olabiliyor zaten yağışlar Akdeniz'de ve
özellikle Yaz mevsiminde karşımıza
çıkıyor çoğunlukla nedeni de bu sıcak
hava dalgaları örnek 2 sorumuzu Ben
çözemiyorum Çünkü bu bir ÖSYM sorusu
ekran görüntüsünü al çöz ve yoruma örnek
2 cevap şu nedeni de bu diye yorum
olarak Bırak diğer arkadaşların da
baksınlar Eğer çözemediler çözebilen
yazsın bunu tamam s örnek 3 örnek 3'ü de
şöyle bırakayım şöyle örnek 3'ü de aynı
şekilde örnek 3 deyip çözüp yoruma
bırakın Bir de gençler Tamam sıcak hava
dalgası var ama soğuk hava dalgası da
var Biz sıcak hava dalgalarıyla
karşılaşabiliyoruz özellikle Güneydoğu
Anadolu'dan gelen o basra'dan dolayı
gelen oradaki çöl kısmından gelen
sıcaklıklarda soğuk hava dalgasıyla o
kadar fazla karşılaşmıyoruz Ama bu biraz
daha kutuplara yakın yerlerde çok
şiddetli görünüyor Tabii bizde de
Erzurum Kars civarına doğru gittikçe
olabilir bakalım Kars ardağın gittiğimde
Aralık ayının sonuna doğru gideceğim ne
kadar soğuk olduğunu ölçeceğim Peki bu
soğuk dalgası neye neden oluyor
canlıların donarak yaşamını yitirmesine
neden olabilir Nehir ve göller donabilir
şunu unutmayın gençler enerji tüketimi
artar sıcak hava dalgasında da artar
soğuk hava dalgasında da sıcak hava
dalgasında klimaları açıyoruz değil mi
soğutmak için soğuk hava dalgasında da
çok ciddi enerji yakıyoruz ısınabilmek
için ulaşım Aksar e ulaşım aksarsa
ekonomik faaliyetler sekteye uğrar
üretim yapılamaz tüketim de Aksar bütün
bunlara neden olabilir soğuk hava
dalgası Evet soğuk hava dalgası
Fırtınalar işte sana sorunun geleceği
kısım Burası diğer sıcak havayı yaparsın
yorumlarsınız yorumlarsınız çıkıyor
karşımıza üniversite sına ve dünya artas
üzerinde soruyorlar bunu bize nasıl
soruyorlar hocam Gençler bu Fırtınalar
bakın 62 km ile 112 km arasında
değişiyor hızları Bunlar çok ciddi can
ve mal kayıplarına neden oluyor ve
bunlar özellikle şöyle haritayı açayım
bakın Bunlar dünyada Tornado vili vili
Kasırga hurrik gibi isimlerle anılıyor
çeşitli yerlerde çeşitli isimler
veriliyor buna Bunlar büyük kasırgalar
gençler Fırtınalar kasırgalar şiddetli
kasırgalar Bunlar çok ciddi can ve mal
kayıtlarına neden oluyorlar tropikal
siklon Bunlar tropikal siklonlar bu notu
yazmanı istiyorum Oraya Fırtınalar
kısmının olduğu yere tropikal siklon yaz
böyle çıkacak testte karşına çünkü
bunlar tropikal bölgelerde yaşanıyor
daha çok neden tropikal bölgelerde
yaşanıyor biliyor musunuz bakın şurası
Ekvator çizgisinin olduğu yer benim mumu
takip edin bana bakmayın bakın şurada
Alize rüzgarları var bunu rüzgarlarda
göreceğiz Alize rüzgarları Ekvator doğru
şöyle esiyor dünyanın dönmesinin
etkisiyle Bir de burada ekvator'da çok
ciddi enerji birikimi var Enerji
birikiminin etkisiyle bu Alize
rüzgarları dönmeye başlıyor enerji var
burada ciddi ve bu dönmeyle beraber
etkilerini alıp İyice böyle güçleniyor
güçleniyor güçleniyor ve burada bakın
Amerika'ya kısmına çok ciddi vuruyorlar
Amerika'da Haberleri sürekli
duyuyorsunuz durur İşte şu Kasırga isim
vermişler Hatta onlara İşte şu Kasırga
geliyor bu Kasırga geliyor diye
Amerika'yı milyarlarca dolar zarara
sokuyor bu kasırgalar ve bu kasırgalar
okyanuslardan buradan gücünü alıyor
tropikal denmesinin nedeni tropik
bölgeden gücünü alıyor tropikal
kasırgalar geliyorlar karaya
girdiklerinde artık gücünü kaybetmeye
başlarlar gücünü Çünkü denizdeki
enerjiden alıyorlardı karaya girince
artık gücünü kaybeder Karanın çok çok
içlerine doğru gidemez böyle belirli bir
süre sonra yok olurlar ama buralarda çok
ciddi yıkımlara neden olurlar bunun
nerelerde görüldüğünü çok iyi bileceksin
bakın şuradan başlattık Alize rüzgarları
geldi tak Amerika'yı vurdu gördünüz mü
şuraya bakın yine Aynısının karşı
tarafında da var Doğu kesiminde şuradan
geldi Hindistan ve Çin bölgesini vurdu
geçirdi gördünüz aynı rüzgarların Bir de
şurada Avustralya kısımlarına vurduğu
kesimi var Şu kısmı da unutmuyorsun
Demek ki avustralya'yı da vuruyor bu
kasırgalar bu harita bizim için çok
önemli geçen sene ayt'de çıktı bakın Bu
geçen sene ayt'de çıktı tyt'de
bekliyorduk biz bu soruyu gittiler
ayt'de sordular Yani bu haritayı
bileceksin Amerika'ya Demek ki vuruyor
burası bu tarafta güneydoğu Asya kısmına
vuruyor Bir de Avustralya kısmı
diyeceksin Anlaştık mı bu harita
önemliydi Evet Fırtınalar bu Bir de
gençler Bunlar Kasırga kasırgalar
tornadolar hurri kler dediğimiz tropikal
siklonlarda E bir de buz fırtınaları var
böyle çok soğuk yerlerde gençler kar
yağışı ya da yağış olduğunda bu yağışın
ardından çok soğuk yaşandığında bir anda
buz tutuyor şuraya bakar mısınız Bunlar
daha çok kutuplara yakın yın yerlerde
görülüyor şuraya bakın Yani yani Şu
arabanın artık kullanılabilir Kullanılıp
kullanamayacağını bilemiyorum kutba
yakın bölgelerde görülüyor Bunlar buz
fırtınaları tutup da orta kısımlarda
Ekvator doğru olan dünya haritası olan
yerlerde bunu işaretlemezsek
soru diyeceğim ama bu da ÖSYM sorusu
çıktı örnek 4 diye yazıp cevabını verin
yorumlara şöyle bıraktım sorusunu çözün
az önce zaten Bununla alakalı bir harita
gösterdim size o haritayı gözünüzün
önüne getirip soruyu çözün Tamam ev Evet
geldik şiddetli yağışlara Peki hocam bu
şiddetli yağışları nerede göreceğim
burada normalin çok üstünde yine Olay şu
kısa sürede normalin çok üstünde yağış
olması nerede göreceğim bunu şöyle
göstereyim size bak özellikle gençler
normalin çok üstünde bir anda Yağmur
düşecek özellikle şu güneydoğu Asya
dediğimiz kesim bu kesimde Yaz
mevsiminde devasa bir yağmur düşüyor
nasıl oluyor biliyor musun Şimdi şu
gördüğünüz kesim gençler şurada Himalaya
dağları var zaten Dağlar çok yüksek
tamam mı Şöyle Bu gördüğünüz kesimde Bir
de rüzgarlarda göreceğimiz basınç
farklarından kaynaklanan 6 ay karaya
doğru 6 ay denize doğru Esen rüzgarlar
var Kış mevsiminde şu gördüğünüz Kara
yüksek basınç oluyor gençler Deniz Alçak
basınç oluyor yüksekten alçağa doğru
rüzgar esiyor bunu basınçlarda
öğreneceğiz Merak etmeyin yani şu şunu
bil şu an Kış mevsiminde Karadan denize
doğru bir rüzgar esiyor şu gördüğünüz
Güneydoğu Asya'da yaşanıyor bu karadan
geldiği için yağmur getirmiyor ama yaz
mevsimi gelmeye başladığında ne oluyor
biliyor musun bu sefer tam tersine
dönüyor bu sefer denizler yüksek basınç
oluyor Karalar Alçak basınç denizden
karaya doğru rüzgar esiyor denizden
karaya doğru rüz Rüzgar esince ne oluyor
denizden aldığı nemi bakın buraları aşıp
Himalaya dağlarına tırmandırır ve şu
gördüğünüz bölgelerde çok ciddi
yağışlara neden oluyor aşırı yağışlar
düşüyor Ve Yaz mevsiminde hep duyarsınız
Güneydoğu Asya'da Hindistan'da sel
felaketi yaşandı Çin'de sel felaketi
yaşandı diye İşte nedeni budur Yaz
mevsiminde 6 ay boyunca durmadan yağmur
yağıyor burada bize aşırı yağmurlar
dediği zaman aklımıza güneydoğu Asya ve
Güneydoğu Asya'daki bu haberler gelecek
şurada Himalaya Dağlarına tırmanıp
Yağmur oluşturuyor buralarda Bak her
taraf nasıl ağaç dağların arkasına
geçince bir kuraklık ve çöl geldi
gördünüz mü Niye böyle oldu çünkü
gençler buraya nem tırmanıyor buraya
yağışını Bırakıyor Ya artık içinde nem
kalmıyor dağın arka tarafına geçtiğinde
F rüzgarlarına neden oluyor rüzgarlar
kısmında göreceğiz Fön rüzgarları
sıcaklığı fön Rüzgarı fön makinesi Sıcak
esiyor sıcaklığı arttırıyor ve bu
sıcaklığı artırdığından arka tarafı
kuraklaşma
ciddi takl kan çölüne neden oluyor benim
Dünyada en sevdiğim oluşumlardan bir
tanesi bu yani görmek istediğim
oluşumlardan bir tanesi ihmal dağları
Belki bir gün hani pek mümkün görünmüyor
ama belki bir gün Hani Yaşlanınca falan
giderim ve şu Taklamakan Çölü Taklamakan
Çölü gidengelmez Çölü olarak
adlandırılıyor Taklamakan aynı zamanda
İpek Yolunun geçtiği güzergahların da
olduğu kısım Silk roat oynarken
Taklamakan çölünden geçerdi ki hep Biz
oyuna da bunu eklemişler Evet böyle bir
durumu var anladık mı buradaki Doğa
kısmını Gençler nasıl nasıl bir doğal
sistemi var görüyor musunuz Allah Nasıl
yani Nasıl yaratmış Nasıl her şey bir
denge halinde buraya yağmur yağıyor
buraya yağışlar düşüyor Buralar hep
bitki ama arka tarafı çöl çok değişik
yani Burası aşırı yağışların olduğu
yerler Evet aşırı ağaçları da gördük
kuraklık gençler kuraklığın olması için
belirli bir bölgede yağışlar normalin bu
sefer çok altında olacak yağışlar
normalin çok altında sıcaklıklar da
arttı topraktaki su da buharlaştı gitti
işte ortaya kuraklık çıkıyor özellikle
Biz kuraklığı nerede göreceğiz şöyle
göstereyim size çöl ve çöle yakın yerler
Hocam ben Çöllerin Yerini bilmiyorum
işte ben sana diyorum ya Hani ilk önce
dünya haritalarını bilmen lazım diye
dünya haritalarını bilmezsen bunları
yorumlayın anlayamazsın da şimdi sen
dünya haritalarını izleseydin özellikle
ilk 34 videosunu izleseydin senin için
çok kolay olacaktı bu gençler Bakın şu
gördüğünüz yer Arizona çöllerinin olduğu
yer bakın Buralar kurak görüyor musunuz
çöl kurak bölgeler Buralar Arizona çölü
geliyorum Bakın bu bölge atakama çölü
çöl deniz kenarı full çöl şuralar full
çöl atakama çölü Buralar kurak yerler
bunları çöl videomu izle temelini
sağlamak şurası bakın Sahra çölünün
olduğu yer Arabistan çöllerinin olduğu
yer kızılkum Karakum Taklamakan Çölü
gobi çölünün olduğu yer şurada tar çölü
vardı Tarhan içe diye kodlamış
tık hatırla şurada bakın Somali'nin
olduğu bölgede de çöl var ha şurada
namip Kalahari Çölü vardı değil mi bu
tarafa geliyorum şurada Büyük Victoria
Gibson Avustralya'nın iç kısmı komple
çöl İşte bu bölgeler kurak bu bölgelere
yakın ve bu bölgeler ve bu bölgelere
yakın yerler kuraklığın olduğu yerler
haritada sana sorulduğunda buraları
işaretleyecek E peki Hocam ben
bilmiyorum çölleri dünya haritasındaki
Çöller videomu izlemen lazım Sen 9 sınıf
öğrencisin 10 sınıfta 11 sınıfta 12
sınıfta tytde karşımıza sürekli dünya
haritaları çıkacak dünya haritaları
kampını öğrenmek zorundasın Bu bir
mecburiyet gençler öğrenmek zorundasınız
bunu senin çölleri bildiğini
varsayıyoruz o kampı öğren öyle devam et
yoluna Tamam gelelim dersimize Evet
kuraklık ha şurada tarımsal kuraklık
kavramında öğrenelim Eğer bitkiler suya
ulaşamıyorsan biz buna tarımsal kuraklık
diyeceğiz bak tarımsal bitkiyle alakalı
bir şey var Tamam bu tarımsal kuraklık
ama Göl Akarsu yeraltı su seviyelerinde
belirgin düşüşler varsa bunlar su bak
hidrolojik kuraklık hidro H2O suydu
değil mi Ha su kuraklığı ymış bu su
kuraklığı ha barajda gölde su azalınca
olurmuş Bak oradan akla gelsin tarımsal
kuraklık tarımda bitki var hocam
bitkilerin suya ulaşamaması diyeceksin
kuraklık neden oluşur yağışın az olması
aşırı sıcaklıklar Çünkü sıcaklıklar
olduğunda su buharlaşıp gidiyor toprakta
su kalmıyor Bir de insanlar da buna etki
yapabiliyor bilinçsiz su tüketimi Bun
Lütfen soru olarak çıkacak karşına buna
Yıldız at bunu böyle maddele ştir not
alıyorsan kuraklığa neden olan olayları
yazınız tarzında Tamam peki kuraklık
varsa bir yerde bunun sonucunda neler
olabilir bir yerde içme ve kullanma
suyuna ulaşmak zorlaşır ve bunun fiyatı
da artar tarım alanları susuz kalır
tarım alanları susuz kalırsa ekonomimiz
bundan etki etkilenir bireysel
ekonomilerde Ülke ekonomisi de bundan
etkilenir enerji sıkıntısı yaşanır
enerji üretemeyiz e aynı zamanda
kuraklık olduğu için daha fazla enerjiye
ihtiyaç da duyarız e suya ulaşamazsak
tarımda verim düşer gıda güvenliği
tehlikeye girer insanlar gıdaya
ulaşamazlar insanlar gıdaya ulaşamazsa
salgın hastalıklar ortaya çıkabilir
gıdaya ulaşamamak suya
ulaşamamaktadır artar ve insanlar artık
kitleler halinde göç etmeye başlar
kuraklık çok tehlikelidir gençler bütün
Bir ülkeyi bitirebilir ülkemizde
Güneydoğu Anadolu ve İç Anadolu
kısımlarında kuraklık şiddeti Her geçen
yıl artıyor O yüzden bizim de bu
kuraklıkla kuraklığa dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor suyu bilinçli bir şekilde
tüketmemiz gerekiyor Evet Bakın şimdi az
önce size haritalarda gösterdim bunları
hangisinde ne yaşanıyor mesela şuraya
bakın güneydoğu Asya Burası neydi orada
o Çin'in Hindistan'ın Bangladeş'in
olduğu yerde şiddetli yağışlar değil mi
şiddet
yağışlar görülür bu tarafa geldim Bakın
bana Çöllerin olduğu yeri gösteriyor sen
artık dünya harası kampını izledin çölün
yerini biliyorsun Arabistan Sahra
çölleri Arizona atakama namip kalar
Büyük Victoria Gibson Kızıl kum Karakum
Taklamakan gobi tar çölü buradaydı yani
Çöller O zaman burada ne var kuraklık
var tamam mı geldik buraya Bakın bu neyi
ifade ediyor şuradan geldi tropikal
siklonlar büyük fırtınalar değil mi
buraya vurdu Hatta şuralara da
vurabiliyorsa
bakın kıtanın tam bittiği yer tundra
ikliminin görüldüğü yer soğuk olan yer
şiddetli soğuklar var burada şöyle soğuk
hava dalgası buz fırtınaları Evet soğuk
hava dalgası buz fırtınaları dersimizin
hava olayları kısmını bitirdik şimdi
gelin bunun sorularını çözelim sayfa
63'ü
açıyorsunuz soru 1 dar bir alanda Aa dar
diyor hava durumu meteoroloji bu etkili
olan kısa süreli atmosfer olaylarına
hava durumu meteoroloji denir aşağı
görünce hangisinin ifadesi Hava durumuna
örnek olarak gösterilebilir bu bu yıl
kış mevsimi soğuk geçecek uzun bir şey
var bakın burada bu Klimatoloji sabah
başlayan hafif yağmur gün boyunca devam
etti kısa süreli bir şey var burada
bakın o zaman bu meteoroloji Diğerlerine
de bakalım yıl boyunca hava sıcak olacak
uzun süreli Klimatoloji her yıl olduğu
gibi bu yıl da kış mevsimi ılık geçecek
uzun süreli Klimatoloji bu bölgeye
senelerdir yağmur düşmedi kuraklık var
uzun süreli klimat olj ama b şıkkı kısa
süreli cevap Bursa geçelim diğer soruya
aşağıd hangisi sinoptik gözlem ve hava
tahmini yaparken incelenen unsurlar
arasında yer almaz atmosferde
gerçekleşen kısa süreli hava olaylarının
meteoroloji uzmanları tarafından araçlı
ve araçsız olarak gözlenmesine sinoptik
gözlem denir bakın hava olaylarını
gözlemleyecek hava olayları sıcaklık
hava olayı nem Rüzgar hava olayı bunları
gözlemleyecek atmosfer basıncı
gözlemleyecek ama azot miktarı bir hava
olayı değil O yüzden onu gözlemlemeyi
azot miktarı gördük mü görmedik Cevap e
geçelim diğer soruya durumlarından
hangilerinin ortaya çıkmasında iklimin
etkisi daha azdır Ege kıyılarında maki
bitki örtüsünün yaygın olması maki bitki
örtüsü Ege kıyıları bitki örtüsü için
iklim gibi uzun süreli bir şey lazım
değil mi bu uzun olmaz Doğu Karadeniz'de
Çay ve fındık tarımının yaygın olması Aa
uzun çay fındık tarım yapacağız iklim
uzun bize iklimin etkisi azdır diyor
Doğu Anadolu'da hidroelektrik
potansiyelinin fazla olması Tabii ki
iklim suyu etkiliyor ama azdır diyor
daha çok Doğu Anadolu'da hidroelektrik
yani barajlar olması burada
hidroelektrik potansiyelden kastımız
barajlar barajların olmasının nedeni
gençler suyun varlığı tabii ki ama
dağlık engebeli olması dağlık engebeli
olduğunuzda olduğunda vadilere çok hızlı
bir şekilde baraj yapabiliyorsunuz
dağlık engebeli olması burada etkili
iklim de etkili ama hangisi daha azdır 3
olan kısımda iklimin etkisi daha azdır
cevap C geçelim diğer soruya Buna göre
artad num olarak gösterilen yerlerden
hangisinde hava durumu ve iklim
özellikleri çoğunlukla birbiriyle
örtüşür yani hava durumu Neyse Bütün yıl
boyunca devam ederse birbiriyle örtüşür
değil mi Ekvator çizgisini çizmeyi
öğrenecektim ben sana ne dedim Ekvator
çizgisini yanlış çizersen her şey biter
Ekvator çizgisini şurada Afrika'nın
hemen o girintisi çizdim o zaman bakın
Bunlar orta kuşak kısmında Burada hava
durumu farklı iklim farklıdır ama
ekvatorun olduğu yerde hava durumu Neyse
Bütün yıl boyunca iklim de odur sürekli
yaz sürekli sıcaktır yıl boyunca da öyle
Evet o zaman cevabımız a geçelim diğer
soruya İstanbul'da 8 Mart'ta kar yağışı
başladı Kuzeydoğu yönlü soğuk hava
kütlelerinin etkisine giren İstanbul'da
yüksek kesimlerde başlayan kar yağışı
Sabah saatlerinde tüm şehirde etkisini
gösterdi şehirde en yüksek hava
sıcaklığı 2 derece olarak ölçüldü kar
yağışının neden olduğu olumsuzluklar
istanbullulara zor anlar yaşatsa da
öğleden sonra açan havayla birlikte kar
yağışı yerini güneşe Bırak bu parçada
verilen habere göre aşağıdaki
yargılardan hangisine ulaşılabilir hava
koşulları mekana ve zamana göre
değişkenlik gösterebilir Evet mekana
yani sabah şöyleydi diyor an Sonra şöyle
oldu diyor mekana ve zamana göre
değişkenlik gösterir bunu gösteriyor
mart ayı sıcaklık ortalaması 2 derecedir
Ben bunu buradan nasıl çıkartayım en
yüksek hava sıcaklığı 2 derece sadece
bir 2 derece ölçülmüş Mart ayının
ortalamasını söylememiş ki bana bulamam
ki evet bir bölgede görülen kısa süreli
hava olayları oy yöreni iklimi hakkında
kesin bilgi verir ya Nasıl Kesin bilgi
versin bir günlük yağmur sıcaklık
değerlerini belirleyen temel faktör
Ekvator olan uzaklıktır ne alaka Ekvator
olan uzaklık sıcaklığımızı etkiliyor
Evet ama onun dışında yükselti yer
şekilleri bir sürü şey sıcaklığımız
etkiliyor İstanbul ölüye kadar yüksek
basınç alanın etkisinde kalmıştır bunu
da çıkartamaz cevapa geçelim diğer
soruya Ali Bey'in teziyle ilgili Rize
Meteoroloji İşleri Genel Müdürlüğünden
aşağıdaki bilgilerden hangisini
Öncelikle elde etmesi gerekir klimat ALJ
alanında yüksek lisans yapan Ali Bey'in
test konusu küresel ısınmanın Rize
bölgesinin ikliminde meydana getirdiği
değişimlerdir tez danışmanı Mahmut Bey
Ali Bey'e Meteoroloji İşleri Genel
Müdürlüğü'nden tezi ile ilgili bazı
verilere ulaşabileceğini söylemiştir Ne
yapacakmış Ali Rize yöresinin ikliminde
meydana getirdiği değişimleri işleyecek
mii küresel ısınmanın Rizeli ikliminde
getirdiği değişimler öncelikle neye
bakması lazım meteorolojik ölçümlerde
kullanılan alete mi Hayır iklim için
bize sıcaklık yağış gibi şey lazım Rize
yaylalarında son 10 yılda düşen karın
kalınlığı karın kalınlığına bakarsan
iklimi ile alakalı tam değişimi
bulamayabilirsin ama Rize'ye ait olan
bakın 10 yıllık kısma bakarsan doğru
olmaz ama Rize'ye ait olan 55060 yıllık
hem yağış hem sıcaklığına bakarsan Sen
aslında iklimine bakmış olurun çünkü hem
uzun süreli 506 yıllığına Bakıyorsun
zaten İklimin en temel faktörleri yağış
ve sıcaklık yağış ve sıcaklığına
bakıyorsun o zaman sen bunun iklimine
bakmış olursun iklimdeki değişimini 5060
yıldaki değişimi bulabilirsin cevap C
geçelim diğer soruya hava durumu kısa
süreli atmosfer olaylarıdır iklim ise
atmosfer olaylarını uzun yıllar
içerisinde gösterdiği ortalama duruma
denir Buna göre Aşağıda verilen hava
Oyların hangilerinin iklim ve hava
durumu doğru eşleştirilmiştir ılıman
kışlar bak kış diyor uzun süre iklim
midir doğru hava durumu soğuk bir gece
Ee kısa süreli Tamam hava durumu kısa
süreli Doğru O zaman cevap A evet
geçelim diğer soruya haritada
dolandırılan alanların hangisinde hava
durumunun yıl içerisinde daha çok
değişmesi beklenir hava durumu nerede
Ekvator çizgimi çizdim hava durumu
burada çok değişmez Çünkü yıl içinde de
sıcaktır günde de sıcaktır yıl boyunca
da sıcaktır Ekvator yıl boyunca sıcaklı
ve yavaştır kutuplar yıl boyunca
soğuktur yıl boyunca soğuktur Ama bu
orta kuşaktadır bir numaranın değişmesi
daha çok değişmesi beklenir cevap A
geçelim diğer soruya aşağıd hangisi bu
değişikliklerden biri değildir buzul
çağından bu yana son 20.000 yılda
ortalama sıcaklıklar doğal süreçlerle
Yaklaşık 4 derece artarken son 100 yılda
insan kaynaklı olarak ortalama
sıcaklıklar 0.9 derece artmıştır insan
kaynaklı küresel iklim değişimi kısa
zaman diliminde doğal sistemlerde
yaşanan bir dizi etkiye neden olmuştur
aşağı hangisi bu değişkenlerden biri
değildir Sibirya bölgesindeki perm frost
adı verilen sürekli donmuş toprakların
erimesi iklim değişirse Topraklar erir
değil mi volkanik olayların yaşanma
sıklığının artması volkanik olaylar
iklimle Alakalı değildir ki jeoloji
yerle alakalı o zaman bunu iklim kısmına
koyamazsın bitkilerin normal zamana göre
daha erken çiçek açması iklimle alakalı
göçmen kuşların göç etmesi iklimle
alakalı buzulların erimesi iklimle
alakalı ama b şıkkı jeoloji yerle
alakalı cevap Bursa geçelim diğer soruya
11 soru biraz daha iklim değişimleri ile
alakalı soru Bu testte olması yanlış
gençler Çünkü iklim değişimlerini biz
sizinle iklim konusunun son kısımlarına
doğru göreceğiz bu konunun son
kısımlarında göreceğiz bu test sorusu
yanlış olmuş ama yine de çözelim aşağıd
hangisi küresel iklim değişim
değişikliğine neden olan beşeri
faktörler arasında gösterilemez Dünya
nüfusunun sürekli artış göstermesi nüfus
beşeri bir faktör değil mi iklim
değişikliğini etkiler ormanların değişik
nedenlerle tahrip edilmesi Evet
ormanları insanlar tahrip ediyor Bu da
beşeri bir şey bunu da eledik dünya
yörüngesinin ve Eksen eğikliğinin
değişmesi Bu insanlarla alakalı bir
durum değil gençler şehir nüfusunun
artması insanlarla alakalı beşeri termik
santral fosil yakıtı insanlar yapıyor
beşeri ama C beşeri değil doğal bir şey
cevap C Evet hava olayları ile alakalı
kısmı bitirdik bundan sonraki videoda
biraz daha E şu ankiloz eli anlaması çok
kolaydı bundan sonraki videoları düzenli
takip etmeniz lazım Eğer ipin ucunu bir
kaçırırsanız anlamakta zorlanırsınız O
yüzden düzenli bir şekilde kampı takip
edin sıcaklık nem basınç Rüzgar bayağı
kapsamlı konular öğreneceğiz Evet bu
dersi de Paraf attık Bir sonraki derste
görüşmek üzere